[Música]
todos nós temos crenças morais
temos valores temos princípios morais só
tem sempre os crimes
todos nós acreditamos na mão dado na
imparcialidade na justiça nós nos
importamos fazer batota de 50 por que e
como é que nós sabemos o que é certo ou
errado moralmente e como é que é isso
que nós sabemos influencia facto as
nossas as nossas ações e decisões morais
é sobre isso que eu queria que pensassem
mais um pouco
pensem presente quando saírem daqui
quando ele ainda que encontrarem na rua
e se encontrarem por acaso uma pessoa na
rua precisar de ajuda à instituição lima
jensen e pude ver que vocês fariam
ajudariam essa pessoa não ajudariam essa
pessoa talvez a maioria de vocês é que
enquanto eu deveria porque não faço
muitos já dizem no âmbito das ciências
comportamentais pretendem estudar isso
mesmo isto é qual é o comportamento das
pessoas em situação quando se deparam
com pessoas com outras pessoas em em
pulsos o que elas fazem essas pendências
o objetivo dessas experiências não é
perceber se as pessoas são boas ou más
elas ajudam a não perceber que fatores
que podem influenciar decisivamente essa
essa ação e artefatos muito simples
podem influenciar essa decisão como por
exemplo está com pressa sim está com
pressa influencia a decisão ajudará na
outro fato uma das experiências mostram
que as pessoas que estão com pressa
estão seis vezes menos disponíveis para
ajudar uma pessoa em pé é precisar de
ajuda
um fato curioso dessa experiência que
ela foi feita com 1 a 1 no seminário
tecnologia compensando isso não estavam
com pressa porque estivesse entre uma
tarefa e eles tinham que escrever uma
parábola sobre o bom samaritano
portanto para em termos alunos
no seminário de teologia que ignoram o
homem firme no chão porque estou com
pressa para escrever uma palavra sobre
vossa maritânia mas há coisas ainda mais
supérfluos que podem influenciar as
nossas decisões
coisas como encontrar uma moeda se
encontrar uma moeda uma dessas
experiências mostrou também que pessoas
que se dirigem ao acamamento fônica para
fazer um chapéu ontem para fazer uma uma
pra fazer uma chamada telefónica que
encontram o que os vão ser protásio uma
moeda essas pessoas nessa experiência
mostrar os 22 vezes mais disponíveis
para ajudar alguém que depois encontra
em instrumento em recurso em situações
de emergência
tanto que isso nos diz diz nos que a
diferença entre uma conduta que nós
consideramos eticamente favorável longo
conduta que nós consideramos eticamente
irrepreensível está menos nos valores os
princípios daquilo que as pessoas
constantemente acreditam e mais na
situação
e reparem como podem ser fatores
completamente aleatório de fatores como
um pouco substantivos porque para
encontrar uma moeda no chão não é uma
conciliação com nós mesmos em conta não
é uma razão que nós conseguiremos válida
para justificar o não se ajudando no
outro mas o facto é que tem tem um papel
e uma outra experiência famosa e que
talvez só você já tenha ouvido falar da
equipe que tenta também mostrar qual
pode ser o peso do contexto na ação das
pessoas a gente pensa que está nem no
meu blog estudar qual é o peso da
autoridade sobre as crenças morais e eu
tenho uma experiência algo
algo problemática do ponto de vista
ético iniciativa fazer e que assim temos
o experimentador o cientista
temos na mesma sala o participante do
estudo que neste caso cumpra o papel do
professor e temos uma sala contígua o
aluno que é culpa de sua experiência
embora o participante não sabe o aluno é
cúmplice da experiência e o que o
professor tem que fazer é simples e é
lhe dito que está em um estudo sobre
memórias os efeitos da punição sobre a
aprendizagem e que o professor tem que
fazer tem que fazer perguntas ao aluno e
sempre que o aluno erra
o professor tem que administrar um
choque elétrico
o choque elétrico em uma de uma voltagem
progressivamente mais elevada poderia
atingir até us 400 volts ou seja um
choque elétrico perigoso e muito moroso
ora nenhum choque foi administrado tanto
usar um pouco mas não tanto nenhum
choque foi administrado só que o aluno
fingia que sim sempre que o professor e
administrava que eu pensava ser um
choque elétrico para o aluno finge onde
estava a dor e pedia para que o estudo
parece que o professor o participante do
estudo neste caso cumpre o papel do
professor
apesar de manifestar algum mal-estar
plantador ethan e pratos pedidos produto
a prazo para que a experiência para as o
que é certo é que perante a autoridade
pra e perante a autoridade
experimentador que existia porque o sul
continuasse porque é importante as
pessoas é que 65% das pessoas levaram
até o fim este estudo portanto 65 cento
as pessoas que aplicaram o que julgavam
ser shox de 400 volts
na outra pessoa apesar das súplicas
apesar das novas sanções da onu
o que quero dizer com isto é por um lado
temos a falar que critério que pensassem
que estamos a falar de pessoas comuns
tentamos a falar de pessoas que foram
foram convocadas com melhor registo na
hora de falar com nossos moraes tem se
falado pessoas como nós pessoas como
vocês pessoas como eu que isto mostra
por um lado também é que
há muitas coisas que podem influenciar
as nossas decisões e embora nós pensemos
que temos sempre na mão duas boas razões
para ser justo humanos temos sempre como
justificações praxe para as posições que
tomamos muitas vezes o que acontece é
uma coisa que enfrenta seja nós temos
uma série de respostas prontas respostas
já prontas para situações com as quais
nos planos muitas vezes o que nós
fazemos é muito simples é consultar as
emoções
consultamos consultamos as emissões e
gostamos e tendo mais vazias com
sentimentos de depressão sentimento de
repulsa e o que parece que quando o que
acontece nesses casos e há também uma
vasta literatura e psicologia no knox
expliquei isso é que nós operamos uma
substituição de uma pergunta isto é nós
queremos saber porque x é moralmente
errado e que como nós respondemos é o
sentimento que quis dizer é que
desencadeia em mim de novo para limpeza
por exemplo neste exemplo porque sexo
sururu e consentido entre irmãos em
momento errado
parece inteiramente errada obviamente
errada
obviamente que é moralmente errado mas
porque temos aquelas razões que nos
parecem óbvias ricos deveriam ser razões
para considerarmos que há uma coisa de
mão
mas falando de sexo fórum sexo
consentido porque quem está errado o que
faz as pessoas que respondiam estas
perguntas é que elas pareciam estar num
estado constante desde que façam mural
isto é elas tinham é convicção um fundo
que estava uma coisa muito errada mas
não conseguiu encontrar um um argumento
racional uma justificação racional que
explicasse isso passa então aí é que
parece haver uma categoria que chama uma
sensação uma convicção e instintiva que
alguma coisa está errada lá e é por isso
que nós consideramos um momento errado e
não porque tenhamos um argumento porque
temos um princípio nacional muito forte
por trás eo mesmo se passa num mesmo se
passa num outro dilema que é o chamado
de lama de petróleo em uma espécie de
pensamento nunca foi feita a fio
mas pensei que estivessem no lugar de
léo dispensa tivessem daquela não
guardar aquela pessoa que tem um ex
governados nada vocês nada fizerem eu
vai matar cinco pessoas é que vocês
podem fazer é assinar o manípulo fazer o
troller dirigir por forma a dar apenas
uma pessoa a par das pessoas perante
este lema que respondeu faz um
raciocínio que é puramente utilitarista
temos cinco pessoas numa linha uma
pessoa ou outra mas vou falar 100
pessoas do que salvar uma certa hora e
se o cenário mudar um bocadinho forem
assim o que acontece neste caso e temos
mesmo mesmo troller de confirmadas as
mesmas cinco pessoas na linha senhor
pode fazer é tirar assumindo temos que
partir desse pressuposto que servirão de
seu golzinho para cima do do rio e vai
parar o elétrico só vai morrer mas vai
impedir a morte de outras cinco pessoas
acontece neste caso é que o padrão de
respostas inverte completamente e apenas
10% das pessoas consideram que é certo
tirar o seu orgulho pra cima da linha
parece exatamente o mesmo tá certo temos
simpsons uma pessoa salvato 5 em vez de
salvar uma porque mubarak mubarak é que
temos um matérias pelas próprias mãos
temos uma relação sexual numa versão
moral pessoal e isso desencadeia um
sentimento negativo muito mais forte e é
por isso que os juvenis momento errado
tanto porque eu acho que parece que tudo
isso é importante para um lado parece
que é importante que nós precisamos
comer com a gente morar real funciona
porque nós queremos fato influenciar o
comportamento das pessoas muito mais do
que importar ou exportar código de
conduta
nós temos que perceber como é que o
agente rural funciona em ação em
situação que está aqui e dizer não é que
não somos uns dias de moraes e morais
não temos princípios não temos valores
temos a questão é quando terminando seus
podem ser em hassan e o que está a dizer
é que é predominante o que está a pôr em
causa a predominância deste processo
racionais liberatti vos muitas vezes há
muitas outras coisas que entrou na
negociação e muitas outras coisas tem
peso moral e kempes na eleição
como a posição perante o outro contexto
as emissões e tudo isso importa porque
nós somos agentes nacionais somos
agentes funcionários um tipo muito
determinado
no tempo em que os automatismos nunca
desaparecem as emissões nunca se cala e
portanto se as nossas decisões não são
flex puro das nossas crenças e das
nossas crenças morais muita muita coisa
pode correr mal e pode correr mal não
por causa do que nós somos e por causa
do que nós acreditamos mas apesar do que
nós achamos que apesar daquilo que nós
acreditamos e portanto todas estas
verdades acerca da forma como nós agimos
moralmente sempre tensas com o tempo de
tantas consequências éticas porque diz
que nós somos vulneráveis somos
imperfeitos podemos facilmente escape à
crueldade fácil - que ir para para a
injustiça e podemos também muito
facilmente ser manipulados nesse sentido
e portanto ter conhecimento disse ter no
sangue se ter noção do que apenas o
nosso nós acreditamos não é suficiente
muitas vezes é um instrumento poderoso
que importa que as pessoas tenham porque
afinal ter noção do que não está em
domínio absoluto é ter um bocadinho mais
do domínio
[Aplausos]